How did MIT undergraduates design a robot
to lift a small model police car and place
it on top of a model of MIT's great dome?
Calculus! In this video, we'll use calculus
to describe the motion of rigid bodies and
see how these concepts are used in the field
of robotics.
This video is part of the Derivatives and
Integrals video series. Derivatives and integrals
are used to analyze the properties of a system.
Derivatives describe local properties of systems,
and integrals quantify their cumulative properties.
Hello. My name is Dan Frey. I am a professor
in the Mechanical Engineering department at
MIT, and today I'll be talking with you about
the motion of rigid bodies--both translation
and rotation.
In order to understand this video you should
be very comfortable with linear motion, including
position, velocity, and acceleration. You
will want to know how to turn measurements
in polar coordinates into measurements in
Cartesian coordinates. You should also know
enough introductory calculus to apply the
chain rule.
After watching this video you should be able
to explain what is meant by the phrase "rigid
body." You should be able to describe restrictions
on the motion of an object by using constraint
equations. Finally, you should be able to
use derivatives and integrals to connect different
mathematical descriptions of rigid body motion.
Our primary examples today will be robots.
Let's look at how basic ideas of motion are
used in the field of robotics. Here you can
see some footage from a robotics competition
at MIT. The competition is part of a Mechanical
Engineering course, number 2.007.
One typical task that robots perform is to
grab something, pick it up, and move it. This
robot uses a gripper, at the end of the arm,
to pick up objects.
One of the difficulties in programming a robot
arm is that we typically have no direct measurement
of where that gripper is. There's usually
no convenient sort of "position meter" that
could tell its location. Instead we might
determine the location for the base of the
arm, and we can measure the angles for different
parts of the arm. We need to use the measurements
that we can make in order to determine the
location of
the gripper.
This is made easier by the concept of a "rigid
body." Rigid bodies can translate and rotate,
but they do not bend, stretch, or twist. In
mathematical terms, the distance between any
two points in the object does not change.
Rigid bodies are idealizations -- to simplify
our work, we imagine that we are working with
objects that do not deform. This idealization
works best when the object only experiences
low amounts of force. Higher amounts of force
can lead to objects deforming or breaking,
depending on the object.
The robot we saw earlier is a good example
of a rigid body. You can see in this video
that as our robot moves, its pieces do not
bend or distort noticeably, so we can treat
each piece as a rigid body. We could use the
definition of a rigid body to help us determine
the location of points on that robot.
This robot, on the other hand, has a less
sturdy frame. You can see the arm flex as
the robot moves. We might not want to treat
this arm as a rigid body. Let's try to solve
a problem involving a rigid body. Here is
a very simple robot arm. It has a "joint"
on the left that can tilt up and down, and
a piston that can extend its arm. In addition,
this part of the piston can be considered
a rigid body, so its length will be a constant.
Here is a task for you: describe the acceleration
of the gripper at the end of the arm.
First, set the origin for your coordinate
system. Then, write an expression for the
x and y position of the gripper in terms of
the quantities shown here.
Once you have that position, use derivatives
to find the velocity and the acceleration
of the gripper.
Pause the video here to carry out your calculations.
Let's take a look at the answer. First, we
need to choose an origin. Let's choose an
arbitrary location as the origin of our coordinate
system. Our robot's joint may be moving, so
we will use a pair of functions x sub j of
time and y sub j of time to describe its location.
X sub j will be the horizontal distance from
our origin to the joint, and y sub j will
be the vertical distance.
We can use derivatives of these functions
to describe any relative movement that the
joint has when compared with our coordinate
system, such as velocity or acceleration.
This slide shows just the X components of
the answer, with the value x sub j indicating
the location of the joint. You can see that
the expressions can easily become complicated
if both s and theta change at the same time.
One reason that we want to know the acceleration
is because some objects respond poorly to
a high acceleration. Here you can see a different
sort of robot arm lifting a car. Instead of
a gripper, these two robots use a forklift
design. Their arms must move very gently,
especially as they slow down, or the car will
fall off. The arms are capable of moving more
quickly, but the robot's designers have programmed
it to use a lower acceleration.
This leads us to a discussion of constraints.
This section will have a few examples, as
well as several opportunities for you to practice.
Be ready to pause the video.
Constraints are any sort of restriction on
a situation. When they can be expressed mathematically,
we refer to Equations of Constraint. These
describe the physical connection between two
or more rigid bodies.
Constraint equations are useful because they
link one variable to another in a way that
reduces the total number of variables in a
problem. This helps to make otherwise impossible
problems solvable. Constraint equations are
used throughout physics and mechanical engineering.
Some fields refer to a similar idea called
"degree of freedom analysis."
Here is a classic example of a situation with
a constraint. The car on this roller coaster
cannot leave the tracks. If the track is circular,
we can use the equation for a circle to constrain
our movement. We can use this to reduce the
number of variables in our equations for the
position of the roller coaster. Rather than
an equation in x and y, we could have equations
in just x, or just y. We could also use constraints
that involve the distance along the track
or another sensible measurement for the situation
we are investigating.
It's important to note that constraints mean
giving up some freedom in our variables. In
our example, we can only specify x or y, not
both. Once we choose a value for x, there
are only two y values that will work.
Here's a situation where you can find the
equation of constraint. A cart is being pulled
across a flat surface, and the wheels turn
without slipping—effectively, the wheel
is constrained to move only by rolling and
not in any other way: no lifting up, no sliding,
no peeling out. Can you find an equation that
connects x, the distance the cart has moved,
to theta, the amount that the wheels have
turned?
Pause the video here to discuss this in class.
Here is an arm that is fairly complex -- it
has many joints. Pause the video and write
down the variables and constants you would
use for this robot.
There are three separate angles that must
be recorded, as well as the extension of the
arm. There are also three pieces of constant
length.
Now we have an opportunity to describe a constraint
in a complex situation. We could choose, for
example, to constrain the motion of the arm
to just the horizontal direction. Because
there are many variables in this situation,
there are many possible ways to satisfy the
constraint.
Write an expression for just the vertical
position of the gripper in terms of the quantities
shown. Once you have done that, answer this
question: how might we move the gripper in
just the horizontal direction?
You should come up with at least two ways
that we could do this, and describe them mathematically.
Your teacher will then lead the class in a
discussion of your answers. Pause the video
here to do this.
Here is a simulation of a "hydrabot" doing
exactly what you just calculated: moving one
end horizontally. You can see that it matches
up quite well with our hypothetical robot.
Examine its motion closely--is this one of
the motions you described? Are there extra
constraints present here? What freedom of
motion did we give up by making our choice?
Let's review.
Today you used derivatives to find the velocity
and acceleration of an object based on its
position.
You also learned the definition of a rigid
body: that it does not bend or stretch when
force is applied.
Finally, you saw that constraint equations
can reduce the total number of equations in
a system, thus making problems easier to solve.
I hope you enjoyed seeing some applications
of basic motion concepts. Good luck in your
further investigation of physics and engineering!